The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BROWN WESTRICK: Good morning.
My name is Brown
Westrick, and I'm
going to be talking to you about
the speech synthesis project.
Our main goal for the
speech synthesis project
was to create
simulated speech using
a model of the vocal tract
in which we would model
the flow of air over time.
There's existing software
called new speech
that already does this.
And we want to deport it to
cell and then improve the speech
quality that it would
afford us by using
additional computational cycles.
So again, new speech
was originally
developed for
linguistics research
but now it's available for free
under the new public license.
It already models airflow in
the vocal tract in real time.
What this means is that there
are no pre-recorded sounds.
Many speech
synthesizers nowadays
have very large
dictionaries of sounds
that they just piece
together and then try
to smooth the
transition between them.
However, this model
attempts to actually do
what the vocal tract is
doing instead of just trying
to imitate the end result.
The quality of the speech,
of this synthesizer,
the way that it exists is not
as high as the current ones that
use the recorded libraries.
But it has potential to
be much better because you
have so much finer control over
all the different parameters.
Our goal was that we
have this software that
would make an acceptable
speech in real time.
We are hoping it would
be able to take advantage
of the additional
computational power of cell
to be able to get an
increase in speech quality.
And I will it over to
Drew who will tell you
about the new speech system.
DREW ALTSCHUL: So
new speech is made up
of three different major parts.
The first of which is just
called the new speech engine.
The second of which is, which
is probably the largest part
of it, which is called Monet.
And then the tube
resonance model,
which is the final part that
actually outputs the sound.
And as [INAUDIBLE],
the basic processes
is you take a text
input standard string
and the new speech
engine will take care of
and transform it into basic
phonetic information, which
they will then deal with
and will take that string
and eventually convert it into
these what we call vocal tract
parameters, which are basically
parameters that can be sent
to the tube resonance model.
And those parameters
will define exactly how
this tube, which represents
the throat and the nasal tract,
changes over time to
represent speech sounds.
And with those parameters, you
can send a signal through it
and create a voice.
So the first part
of the example will
take a perfectly normal string,
like "all your base are belong
to us," and transform
it into what we
call the phonetic format of it.
And you can see it highlighted.
The actual sounds
are highlighted,
whereas various parameters are
also included in the output
string, like /w, and you can
determine where the words are.
And [INAUDIBLE] which
determine where sentences
and various phrases end.
And basically, Gnuspeech
makes uses of dictionary files
as well as some basic
linguistic models in order
to create this phonetic output
from the basic input string.
So having created
that phonetic model,
you can then send it to Monet,
which is by far the largest
part of the program,
which in turn will take
the phonetic information,
and as I said,
use what a basic
diphone file, which
takes a very large range
of sounds and characters
and will then transform
these phonetics
into direct parameters,
which can represent
the changing of a throat
the entire nasal tract
as you voice your own speech.
So Monet has to go through a
long process of calculating
these phrases given the whole--
the rhythm, the intonation
of the phrase that's
being given to Monet.
And also, a very important
part of the Monet process
is by taking each phrase
and the postures--
is what we call the output.
Looking at the phrase and piece
by piece examining the sounds
and realizing that as the
postures of the throat change,
there are important changes
being made between there.
And basically having some sort
of-- basically a slow change
between them, not a
gradual conversion
as opposed to a sudden
change in the actual shape.
So then having outputted
the basic postures,
you finally send it to the
Tube Resonance Model, or TRM,
which will take the vocal tract
which is divided into eight
sections in this model.
And send a signal
off of a sine wave
through the modified
tube resonance model.
And therefore, all the changes
that occur as time goes on
and the postures
which change the width
of the tube at various
stages will then
cause different speech patterns
to come out and basically
create an actual speech pattern,
which is usually recognized.
So basically you have these
three parts from a basic string
to phonetics to throat
postures until finally you
get the actual speech out.
So now I'm handing
it over to Joyce
to talk a little bit about
the resources and algorithms.
JOYCE CHEN: Well, before
I talk about the resources
and algorithms, I'll talk a
little bit about the TRM, which
is the tube resonance model.
So we already talked
about how Monet outputs
like two parameters
based on transitions
between different words
and postures and so on.
And the tube resonance
model actually
simulates the physics
of the vocal tract.
First you have a glottal source.
If you have done
any linguistics,
you might have heard
the little clicking
sound the glottal source makes.
There are different ways to
simulate the glottal source.
Now, ideally, the way you have
a good, natural glottal source
is you have a simulation
of the physics between two
oscillating masses as you
air passes through them.
Now, back in the days
when, say, people
were doing speech
research on gnu speech,
actually simulating the physics
of glottis was not possible.
So what they did
instead was, you know,
they would try a half
sine wave or they
would research the most natural
sounding glottal pulse shape,
initialize a wave table,
and do table lookup
on it, updating it
with the amplitude
and so on to change
it a little by little.
So one of our goals
was possibly to--
because we harnessed the
additional computational power
and make more natural
sounding speech.
And now I'll talk about
allocating the resources.
For example, in
new speech Monet,
there is not as
much computation.
Monet has a lot of rules.
For example, between
postures and postures,
like different shapes
of vocal tracts,
you can't just do an
linear interpolation
to smoothly change.
There are different
rules beach in order
to change between
the postures which
greatly affects the speech.
This was much harder to improve
on, like to parallelize.
Then the tube resonance model.
It had a lot more computation.
In fact, the thing
that took probably
most computation was
after we got our signal
data from the mouth
end of the simulation,
we would have to up
sample or down sample it.
And that was something
that had a lot of potential
to be parallelized.
However, when you were
simulating the tube presence
model, you could only update the
signal inside the vocal tract
incrementally.
If you were to break it
up, there was a possibility
that there would be a lot
of pops in between when
you try to space them together.
We thought about trying to
resolve that with interpolation
between forms.
There were nested loops.
The main synthesized
thing had nested loops.
You had a posture.
And then you simulate
on the posture
and between the postures.
And that took the
most computation,
as well as updating
the glottal wave table.
All right.
Now I will hand it off to Omari
to explain the challenges.
SPEAKER 5: So the
TRM algorithm, which
is-- we're most
focused on trying
to-- so we most tried to
focus on parallelizing the TRM
algorithm.
Because both Gnuspeech and
Monet are almost entirely
just dictionary
lookups involving
large amounts of memory with
not that much computation.
So there wasn't really
that much potential
for parallelizing those.
So we looked at the tasks
that were being done on TRM
and profiled them.
And you can see what
took most of the time
was the noise generator
part, like the attempt
at the glottal source
that was being put
into the tubes and
the actual updates
where the tubes are supposed
to be as they were shifting.
And so unfortunately, the
main loop as this was updating
was very, very fast.
It was about 15 microseconds.
So it would be pretty difficult
to update, for example,
several SPUs as fast
as we needed them to,
considering how communication
costs affect them.
So parallelism was not
very simple to use.
Our main, original idea for
this exploiting parallelism
was to make a pipeline of the
various parts of the TRM model,
maybe using three or
four SPUs, like one
for each part of the
throat as a sound would
go from one to the next.
So that all of them would
be engaged simultaneously,
like going from one posture to
the next in a linear fashion.
But unfortunately,
the timing for this
was very, very fast, in the
order of about 70 kilohertz,
which is many times
a second for SPUs
to be transferring data
back and forth to each other
with mailboxes and memory.
So that was somewhat difficult.
OMARI: Unfortunately,
with this project,
we faced a number of
challenges, the first
and foremost being
that Gnuspeech
is written in a programming
language most of us
weren't familiar with.
And it's huge.
Monet, for example,
is 30,000 lines.
It's hardly documented.
And it took a fair
amount of time
just reading through and
figuring out what was going on.
Additionally, because
it uses Gnustep,
which is a GUI library,
the calls are asynchronous
and it makes it tremendously
difficult to debug as well.
I had tried to convert part
of it to C++ to try to get
the tube running
on one of the SPEs,
and that took three
days in and of itself.
And I ended up having to
toss that attempt out.
Another problem we had was
dynamic pointer alignment.
In Objective C,
most of the objects
are stored as dynamic pointers.
And basically in
Objective C, there's
also no malloc alignment
or anything of that nature.
So we couldn't really
transfer any of the objects
from Objective C memory area
to the SPUs to work on the data
and then send them back.
So what is working now?
We are able to do line buffered
text in the Gnuspeech engine
and translate that
to utterances so
the-- phonetic pronunciations.
And get to the point where we
would execute the tube model.
Unfortunately, one of
the-- a bug in Gnuspeech
potentially is preventing
us from properly executing
the tube model right now.
So that's one thing we're
having problems with.
Additionally, the
tube runs on the PPE.
We've been trying to get
the tube to run on the SPE,
but it's not going well, partly
because of the dynamic pointer
alignment issue and partly
because of some other things
we've run into.
Currently not working.
As Drew had mentioned,
there are a lot
of dictionary lookups
in the preprocessing
stage of the pipeline.
And there's a bug
in Gnustep where
it won't parse the dictionary
if it's above a certain size.
The dictionary has I
believe 70,000 entries,
it takes up almost 3 megabytes.
But if there are more
than like 3,000 entries
in the dictionary, it
just doesn't parse.
And we have no idea why.
So to conclude, this was a
tremendously difficult problem.
There are a bunch
of data dependencies
and the synchronization
is very, very close.
However, we feel
that with more time
and with more experience
with the code base,
we would have been
able to parallelize it.
And the parallelization
can almost
definitely help
the vocal quality
in terms of naturalness.
Getting, for example,
as Joyce mentioned,
a higher quality glottal source.
Speaker identification
and vowel identification.
For example, when you
pronounce different vowels,
sometimes quality the
glottal source changes.
And lastly, it would be worth
the time to re-write the whole
thing from scratch, skipping
Gnustep, skipping Objective C,
and going with C++ or most
likely C for the whole thing.
Thank you.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: It sounds
like you guys
are taking a fine-grained
approach in which you're
splitting the application
across different units.
Since you're synthesizing
completely independent words,
let's say, could you just
run the whole application
on an SPU?
There's engineering there,
but from a parallelization
standpoint, can you just
take the whole application
and run it, for example,
on different words?
OMARI: So I believe
you're suggesting
we run the tube
on different SPEs
and then feed data to the
separate instances of the tube
from the PPE?
AUDIENCE: Well, including--
the whole processing backline.
I mean, order the sentences
from one sentence to the next?
OMARI: So the big
stumbling block for us
was that there isn't
currently an Objective C
compiler for the SPEs, so
we can't run the Objective C
code on the SPEs at all.
AUDIENCE: But if you
did it from scratch,
if you were to write your
own-- just throw away
all your Objective C
and start from scratch,
would that be a better
parallelization strategy
than a fine-grained one?
OMARI: Possibly.
So one of the disadvantages
of splitting up words
is that there is
state that connects
the different-- [INAUDIBLE]
continuous state that connects
the different postures
vocal tract all
the way through the utterance.
And so we would have to do
possibly some prediction,
possibly some
interpolation to figure out
how to connect the different,
separate utterances which
should been produced
consecutively.
AUDIENCE: Permitting
one sentence
at a time or something?
OMARI: Yeah.
That might be an option, yes.